es tu prêt pour le défilement pourquoi
[Musique]
ni je suis prête à vivre avec une autre
chance même s'il ya deux ans on est quoi
poule à des coups fumants parce qu'on en
a marre
qu'est ce que les gestes barrière
respecté à mettre avec tout afin de
lever les mains très souvent et porter
un masque dans son coude au budget les
droits collier qui on est
distance avec mes preuves et qu'ils
portaient une masse aurait fait quand on
sort il faut se laver les mains
il faut tout c'est notre coup ils font
schéma monsois glace tu n'y es tu
les abonnés mais big en masse c'est cela
oui marie lizin a sorti tient sans
qu'elle sait qu'elle allait la prendre
place à ce que ce que la distanciation
social de respecter à mettre 10 ans avec
les personnes et nos profits jusqu'ici
elle seule celle ci garder ses distances
et du batteur a sonné par jeff on ne
vous parle ce diable de la main fait des
câlins à m c'est quand on reste un peu
amusé avec les autres battre appel
commun
[Musique]
comment vois-tu ces premiers jours
d'école
le premier jour d'école je les vois
comme pas comme le zouk pas comme nous
précédente je vois commissaire s'ils
voient que maîtresse et va rentrer il y
aura un gel hydroalcoolique ont commis
ajouté que je pourrais jouer dans les
classes
je m'imagine avec vous je serais très
content de rejoindre les copains mais ce
sera difficile de ne pas s'approcher
d'eux
[Musique]